Україна посіла 29 місце в щорічному
міжнародному рейтингу 136 армій світу Global Firepower.
Це на одну сходинку краще, ніж торік. Втім,
ще у 2014-му Україна була на 21-му місці.
Тобто за роки війни на сході України здала позиції
в рейтингу, хоча отримала справжній бойовий досвід і краще забезпечення.
Як таке могло статися?
Рейтинг Global Firepower враховує понад півсотні показників  країни -
від географічного розташування і природних ресурсів
до розвитку промисловості.
Ядерний арсенал при цьому не відігравав визначальну роль:
за наявність ядерної зброї, як і за членство в НАТО,
лише нараховувались бонуси. При цьому є і система штрафів.
Зокрема, за нерозвинений флот попри наявний вихід до моря,
великий зовнішній борг, погане покриття доріг та інші фактори.
Так от саме через ці фактори Україна суттєво відстає.
Передусім через воєнно-морські сили, які зазнали значних втрат внаслідок анексії Криму.
За рівнем розвитку ВМС Україна на 75 місці,
між Гватемалою і Демократичною республікою Конго.
Авіаносців, есмінців і субмарин немає. З головних сил -
лише один фрегат "Гетьман Сагайдачний", один мінний тральщик та один корвет.
Серед інших причин невисокого місця в рейтингу –
значна втрата військової техніки та озброєння внаслідок бойових дій на Донбасі.
А також особливості підрахунку, приміром, оборонного бюджету.
В гривнях він щороку зростає, але по факту,
в доларах майже не змінився.
За період війни в Україні іншим державам вдалося
ефективніше розвивати свої війська.
Тобто хоча українська армія стала дієвішою,
в інших країнах краща економіка і немає бойових дій,
тож вони мали змогу більше інвестувати у військо
й піднялися вище в рейтингу.
Додатково Global Firepower визначає ще так званий
індекс моці. І цей показник в України
з кожним роком покращується. Тож, на думку експертів,
реальна обороноздатність держави
і боєздатність армії підвищується.
Ситуація з іншими країнами в рейтингу така.
Перша п’ятірка без змін. Наймогутніша армія у США,
далі йдуть Росія, Китай, Індія та Франція.
Німеччина - на 10-му місці, а Польща – на 22-му.
На останньому ж місці – азійське королівство Бутан.